okay i thought he was going to move the  bishop yeah white's bishop could move  white's king can now go  kind of the long way around to support  beth marching forward  there we go  that pawn is going to become a new queen  it's going to cost black a knight and  look white will still have two remaining  pawns gary and beth  yeah it's just too many pawns here and  black's pawn  under lock and key  yeah i must say a superb performance  from the world champion today  yeah i'll tell you if he's done well but  he hasn't really stood a chance  unfortunately he's tried his best but it  hasn't been enough and now look at this  one pawn marches forward one is blocked  the other goes and that causes artemis  to resign  magnus carlsen is the winner of the aim  chess u.s uh rapid his third tournament  victory in the meltwater champions chess  tour 2021 a dominant performance here in  the final by the world champion he is  looking  so sharp so fierce magnus crawls and  before the big turf